five it's been a dramatic old season on
Game of Thrones this one has if it could
get any more dramatic red wedding what
was your reaction to that episode well
having read the book and knowing it was
going to happen even then reading it it
was really shocking and it is very
understand tonnes a whole lot of stuff
on the weather people we didn't know was
coming seeing it coming and it was
played so beautifully so horribly and so
feelingly that was when when Catelyn
knew she was gone that a summer that it
was heartbreaking I mean apparently the
the crew were crying and although I was
not surprised brilliantly brilliantly
done David Bradley was just awesome
when we were shooting the previous scene
where we arrived and he introduced his
daughters he has about 20 daughters with
strange names which sound all the same
he did it 75 times because we were there
all day doing this side that side what
carrot this guy and he did it perfectly
every time fantastic he's a wonderful
actor what a memory
obviously you blame blackfish and you
were at the wedding but it managed to
get out of there fortunately the who do
you think black fish would like to take
his revenge on now Charles dance a very
very slow death perhaps tearing his skin
off with a very sharp knife and then
killing it I wonder if black fish would
have that would actually feel like that
himself I don't know I think
it's a horrifying thing to have
to fall for it I mean though the idea
that you fell for it that he could do
something as treacherous really
horrifying I mean that was part of it
you could hardly believe that somebody
would go that far for something
apparently so trivial and yet that was a
lesson that the boy King didn't learn
it's statehood first love second if you
could bring any of those characters back
that we sadly lost in that episode who
would you bring back to life I think I
bring Kaitlyn back to life just a
fantastic a fantastically rounded woman
and uh I guess it's something to do with
the performers as well I'd bring them
all back really cuz it's a I wonder if
by getting rid of the Starks you may
have preempted the end of the series in
a kind of way I mean I don't know
obviously the books go on and on and on
but somehow you've removed if you like
the good guys they're not inside they're
flawed and all of that but it's that's
part of the shop you might you can't
imagine you're gonna take them away it
was such a shot when Shawn got his head
cut off and now to carry on with it
pretty unlucky family very rich aren't
they I mean what do you think's left for
the Starks now exists obviously this is
the left and there's a bran and Rickon
as well a long gap before they even have
a chance of getting back into the game
in truth I mean all the although the
northern Lords have deserted them they
have no political support they have no
adults to lead the mother unless the boy
comes back from the north and it and he
would never be accepted anyway so it's a
it's a very very black component in the
history of that family when it's in
various kind of theories flying around
online and one of them's called the
Lannister honey parks period and if
you've heard about it were some people
were speculating whether Talisa Oona
Chaplin's character might have been sent
by the Lannisters sort of feat robbed in
some way what do you think of that Wow
that seems to me intriguing and
fascinating I don't think that's I'd
know
and what kind of qualities do you think
you need to stay alive and Game of
Thrones so do you think blackfish has
those qualities that he needs to keep
alive apparently you need to go to the
toilet just at the right moment with sin
number one you need to be able to look
after yourself physically you need to be
a soldier and that's number one it's not
a there is diplomacy there are delicate
skills going on somewhere but in the end
it's the guy who has the political clout
to get somebody to kill enough people
for them and certainly blackfish even if
he had the support of the northern Lords
I doubt if he's he's not King general
material he's a soldier a very very fine
soldier and a very good family man and
who do you think will be there left
standing at the end of the day when
obviously george RR martin has finished
Oliver chair but when though all the
books are done when all the TV series
have been that who do you think will be
left under Charles dance
and his horrible family how do you think
you'd fare in black fishes world's it's
such a such a harsh terrible stark world
they live in ISM
I've often thought I mean given that my
father's generation went to war if you
as a boy you grew up thinking could I do
that
could I be brave enough to face the
possibility of my dying or the person
next to me dying and I always come up
with the answer that I'd be the one
who'd be terrified I'd be the one who'd
be shaking in a corner unable to get out
of the trench or trying to find some
excuse not to get into the bomber to go
bombing people but then that was true of
my father's generating it with just
ordinary guys like me in the end if you
have to do something like that you'll do
it it's clear that there I played rugby
with guys who were I was going to say
very rude word there who are are almost
mad in their capacity for a certain kind
of violence and you know that in the
generations that were soldiers those are
the guys that you need around because
they get their blood up so quickly
they're capable of doing anything I'm
not that kind of person but you can
never second-guess who you'd be if
somebody killed one of your children
what would you do what would I do I
don't know but the answer to your
question is no I don't think I'd survive
in that world it's such a we say such a
brutal world with so many deaths least
of all in the red wedding but throughout
the whole three seasons I mean if we had
to lose blackfish how would you like to
see him go out killing Charles dance
so challenging stupidly challenging him
to a duel but somehow winning it or any
of them yeah yeah nothing nothing
against Charles doesn't and what are you
most looking forward to going back to
work the season for what just had to see
how the character is developed I mean
there's been some it's interesting
reading the blogs that there are people
who have great fans of the books who are
very uncomfortable about the way in
which the TV series has realized
blackfish it's not quite what they
imagined they wanted a more gentle
uncle' familial man family duty honor
blackford for blackfish i think in the
books is definitely family first so I
imagine that the qualities he had in the
scene with Catelyn at the very beginning
when he first arrived other ones which
would be developed in the future but you
never know he may become a maniacal
revengeful soldier again even for such
an old man
you